all right with less covert restrictions
more things opening up and you know the
the vegas summer spring vibes that we've
all missed coming back it's a good time
to remind you about the dangers
and consequences of duis i spoke with
law vegas now expert eric palacios to
learn more
see you good to be here thank you of
course we are talking about something
very important duis especially now that
vegas is opening up
people are in these streets so first
question here what will get you a
dui if you have over 8.8
blood alcohol level then this will get
you to
a dui level of being impaired so it's
very important that
even though everybody's starting to uh
to go out to uh let loose a little bit
to still be very very careful
in your drinking uh if you drink please
don't drive
so just a quick question here how many
glasses of wine for example would that
beak
it depends on a lot of things uh your
size your weight your height your age
male or female
for some people it's as little as two
drinks the majority of people it's about
four drinks
maybe a little bit more but the rule of
thumb is if you've had two drinks
be careful uh it's a lot better just to
call a
right service and uh not risk it
definitely and what does it mean to be
in control of your vehicle a lot of
great questions a lot of people don't
realize you can be in your vehicle with
the keys in your pocket with no intent
to drive
and still be charged with a dwi
that means that even though you're not
uh driving the car
uh the car doesn't even have to be
turned on but just the fact that you
could turn it on if you
if you wanted to you have control you
have the keys in your hand in your
pocket
uh that can be enough to mean that you
intended to drive and that is a crime of
itself a lot of people say well i'm
going to sleep it off and they sit in
the front seat
with the car turned on listening to
music that can be enough to get you into
trouble so it's a bad idea to do that
wow that is a great reminder something
people might not actually know so what
are the consequences
of a dui or a dwi there's a lot of
negative consequences first
obviously you usually get arrested you
spend between two days
up to six months in jail you have to pay
fines you have to go to a dui school
you have to go to a victim impact panel
where you hear
others tell their stories of how their
lives were impacted by
a dui it stays on your record for uh
seven years and on top of that your
insurance rates uh
increase and you lose your license
temporarily so a lot of negative
uh results from being convicted of a dui
it's just not worth it call a friend
call an uber lift whatever you can do i
always say that call uber tonight or
you'll be calling me tomorrow and i'd
rather you make the first call
that's a good one that's a good one okay
anything else to remind our viewers
about duis
uh just be very careful if you or a
friend
if you think they're impaired don't risk
it you're gonna get caught
uh or worse you're gonna hurt yourself
or hurt somebody else
so uh just be overly cautious if you've
had a few drinks
uh and get a right chair home all right
thank you so much eric great reminders
as always
thank you for having me for more
information just give eric palacios and
associates a call at 702-444-7777